il ya quelques heures pétain dit il a
été pendant la première guerre mondiale
un grand soldat
même s'il a conduit des choix funeste
par la suite
et bien cette prise de position est
critiquée par un certain nombre de
responsables politiques je vous cite
juste 2 de réaction celle de jean luc
mélenchon pétain est un traître et un
antisémite
ces crimes et sa trahison sont
imprescriptibles macron cette fois ci
c'est trop l'histoire de france n'est
pas votre jouet et puis une réaction
aussi un tweak de francis khalifa qu'est
le président du conseil représentatif
des institutions juives de france le
crif et qui dit la seule chose que je
veux retenir de pétain c'est qu'en 1945
il a été frappé d'indignité nationale ce
qui le rend inéligible à un quelconque
hommage et bien comme nous interrogions
l'histoire nous allons interroger
d'historiens sauf de boeck votre point
de vue oui sauf que sur train de
travailler sur cette île et itinérance
mémorielle et pour vos étudiants de
sciences po
exactement et je trouve que c'est
passionnant comme comme des barrages
lire au delà de dates de settat c'est
passionnant parce que c'est toute la
question de la relation entre histoire
et mémoire qui est véritablement vous
savez la grande phrase de pierre nora
l'histoire n'est pas la mémoire bon or
en france et pas seulement en france
donc dans le monde entier on peut dire
la mémoire et de la remplacer l'histoire
qu'est ce qui se passe avec pétain moi
je suis historien c'est à dire l'homme
de la complexité il ya bien de pétain et
un pétain qui a en effet a bien été le
vainqueur de verdun et qui a été en plus
stratégiquement intelligent à verdun il
n'a pas seulement eu de la chance est là
il a bien joué son affaire et puis elle
vers dingue de 40,1 de pétain de pardon
de 40 et donc en historia je dis oui
c'est toute la complexité de pétain est
évidemment vous avez vu les réponses des
réponses ne parle que de mémoire un
dignité hommage commémoration et c'est
le problème que j'ai là dessus
moi je donne donc entièrement raison sur
le fond à emmanuel macron le grand
problème c'est que lui-même s'est fait
le grand champion de la mémoire et que
vous savez sur d'autres sujets algérie
par exemple il n'a pas été
particulièrement on va dire équitable
historiquement il amenait un parle de
crimes contre l'humanité en parlant de
la colonisation historique pose un peu
des problèmes d' anachronisme par
exemple bon en tout cas il ay là il a il
a peut-être lancer la faim moi je suis
je trouve ça très intéressant plus idée
c'est un grand spécialiste de la mémoire
vous savez qu'il a travaillé avec
rigueur sur ce sujet c'est pas c'est pas
lasser
il débarque pas et musclé c'est donc
d'autant plus passionnant d'examiner
d'examiner ce qu'il fait comment il le
fait à quel moment il le fait est là
peut-être encore ils envoient déjà une
façon encore des messages
contradictoires se fait de ravinel et le
président n'a plus qu'a pris un risque
là il aurait pu passer pour annoncer
publiquement sur eux sur ce sujet je
vous rappelle que c'est tous les ans que
cette cet hommage a lieu aux invalides
et j'allais dire c'est ce sont les
circonstances qui changent j'allais dire
tout à l'histoire et même enfin voila
c'est les circonstances et ce moment
c'est cette semaine qui était déjà
extrêmement compliqué pour lui
c'est ce un phénomène européen dont nous
parlions précédemment qui est aussi
complexe
c'est les phrases même qu'il a prononcée
sur la période des années 30 c'est tout
ça qui forment une espèce d'ensemble et
dans lequel il leur est dû à mon avis
tout faire sauf s'engouffrer alors
peut-être qu'il a voulu lancer cela en
matière de communication ce dont je
doute pour d'autres raisons quand t'es
pas le temps d'expliquer mais je me
doute je me demande certains disent il a
voulu lancer là pour évacuer la question
des gilet jaune et basculer sur autre
chose et c'est à une autre polémique
voilà mais c'est d'un danger kiki qui
est quand même on va là d'un point de
vue politique moi non plus mais d'un
point de vue politique ça peut
s'entendre mais je pense que ce sont les
circonstances qui rendent extrêmement
j'allais dire maladroite
cette déclaration alexis lacroix il a eu
tort ou à raison mais macron il a eu
raison
sur le plan strictement historique mais
là je rejoins de voc peut-être pour
élargir son propos
c'est vrai que quand on fait une
commémoration on est dans le présent
puisque c'est pauline à la c politique
de mai matin car ces politiques d'avoir
s'incarne dans une dans une actualité
dans une réalité présente donc les deux
pétain oui bien sûr ça existe aussi
voilà pour les trois mais l'intrigué
aguerris le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui
et là c'est le goût grand reproche que
je fais personnellement à emmanuel
macron qui pourtant est capable de
subtilité mais là il manque de subtilité
il ya une réhabilitation dans des
franges entières de la droite de pétain
de la figure de pétain il ya le retour
de la théorie du glaive et du bouclier
d'ailleurs les pires dans sa défense ne
sont pas ceux qu'on
on nomme souvent ce n'est pas eric
zemmour mais il ya le retour de cela il
ya le retour de ces discours de
l'équidistance entre de gaulle et pétain
qui est un discours extrêmement toxique
qu'est ce que fait emmanuel macron il
tient pas compte de ce contexte
idéologique et pourrait rendre
absolument décisif et il donne le
sentiment à des gens qui sont les
gardiens de la mémoire juive comme
khalifa le crif il donne le sentiment
qu'au fond garder quelques paris dédain
mais parce que malheureusement tous ces
gestes là sont politiques cette semaine
et politique
il donne le sentiment qui quelque part
on pourrait dédramatiser en clonant en
monsieur laissez moi dire en tenant
compte de l'existence d'un deuxième
pétain bien sûr que ce deuxième pétain
existé mais le moment n'est pas venu de
le célébrer je regrette donc
profondément ce geste des manières
d'afrique
je pense à mon père je pense que c'est
tout oui je pense que c'est une faute
politique de le faire dans ce moment-là
il manuel macron devrait ouvrir les yeux
sur la réalité dans les soubassements
idéologiques du pays de ses tentatives
de réhabilitation de pétain à laquelle
malheureusement son initiative risque
indirectement et involontairement de
contribuer donc oui c'est une faute
c'est sale et plus unie terence
mémorielle c'est une errance mémorielle
et ça va devoir de le voir et ont triplé
et il faut que le président il faut que
le président si j'estime beaucoup
s'explique là dessus très peu de mon
temps de parole à mon ami edouard si
vous insistez non parce que en fait on
comprend intellectuellement mais dans le
moment que vit le pays on ne comprend
plus rien nous nous avons enfin je sais
pas mon histoire de france du 20e siècle
il ya de repères avec les deux guerres
il ya la guerre de 14-18 cesser cette
incroyable moment d'unité d'unités du
pays là pour une fois
alors qu'au 19ème c'était pas le cas on
verra quand 1940 ce sera plus le cas
mais pour une fois les les catholiques
les non-catholiques les bourgeois les
ouvriers les paysans les tout un pays
sera serré lancé se réconcilient face à
l'ennemi il y a
l'ons les hiérarchies et reprennent
enfin c'est un moment
l'union sacrée c'est une c'est quelque
chose à célébrer fortement alors on
comprend le vainqueur de verdun mais en
fait on comprend plus c'est compliqué et
on est à deux jours d'une date très
gaullienne le 9 9 en bon l'unité en 14
et la résistance sont 40 c est ce qu on
peut pas essayer de dans les journées
d'itinérance qui ne doivent pas devenir
une errance politique est ce qu'on ne
peut pas se raccrocher à des choses un
peu un peu simple et forte qui sont les
piliers de ce pays de notre dynamique
dont on a besoin aujourd'hui
comprenez dommage à titre personnel que
cette itinérance mémorielle même si le
un peu pompeux comme un comme
appellation il ya quelque chose d
extrêmement beau et moi j'ai lu un
nombre d'articles vraiment remarquable
et passionnant sur toute cette période
là et je m'en suis délectée et j'ai
vraiment aimé relire tous à vivre dans
cette atmosphère et on la voit
totalement paralysée par les gilet jaune
et par cette polémique sur pétant et
c'est extrêmement mal seul est valence
la mémoire résulte de la nitroglycérine
bozec j'ai toujours un peu peur
vis-à-vis des politiques de mémoire
c'est de la nitroglycérine surtout dans
une situation d'une société extrêmement
divisée polarisée et ses enjeux passe
par la mémoire justement cette division
passe par la mémoire nous ayons ce qu'on
appelle la concurrence des victimes
il faut faire très très très attention
et même si le maquereau est un ex bras
droit tiers rappelez-vous en effet
d'aider des propos sur l'algérie là ça
repart ça va partir à tous les coups
je crois qu'il faut faire très attention
parce que c'est extrêmement encore une
fois c'est très dangereux actuellement
je ne sais même pas comment il faudrait
faire il n'a pas les moyens qu'avaient
le général de gaulle de dire c'est comme
ça là l'histoire c'est moi qui l'écrit
et voilà ça c'est fini je gens comme
vous le citez jeu je profite pour
rappeler cette cette phrase du général
de gaulle qui je crois dans un discours
qui prononçait en 1966 en parlant de
pétain la gloire qui la quitte à verdun
et qu'il garda en conduisant l'armée
française à la victoire ne saurait être
contestée dit méconnu par la patrie et
dans la même phrase disaient qu'ils
avaient aussi
le pépin de 40 qui s'était perdue
quelques réactions d'internautes de pâte
qui disaient mes profs dans les années
60 faisait l'éloge de pétain de 4 du
pépin de 14-18 et ça ne dérangeait
personne n guerre de vies la prise de
position inverse pétain et l bassement
électoralistes ou à un autre degré du en
même temps monsieur babineau considère
que soit on célèbre l'ensemble des
acteurs d'un événement ou personnes et
olympe considère que macron et soit
maladroit soit manipulateur voilà les
principales réactions sur ce dossier
benjamin griveaux en un porte-parole du
gouvernement a soutenu la position du
pression d'un public dont on rappellera
que il ne se rendra pas lui-même à cet
hommage rendu aux maréchaux je crois que
c'est son chef d'état major particulier
qui leur présentera le 11 novembre et se
fait de ravinel puisque vous appréciez
les témoignages sur la première guerre
mondiale
en avant première le figaro magazine du
week-end prochain un très grand dossier
consacré à des héros anonymes qu on a
retrouvé des dizaines de soldats
d'officiers de genre complètement
inconnu et qui ont une une conduite
absolument remarquable pendant ce
conflit que veut dire